[Musica]
quando mi hanno proposto questo talk
confesso ero un po un po indeciso perché
ma faccio l'ingegnere tutti i giorni del
week end magari provo a rilassarmi un
attimo e poi life on mars
parliamo di marte ne parlano tutti è
molto molto di moda in questo momento
arrivato appena un rover quindi che dico
decine di milioni di chilometri il tempo
radio e poi ho riflettuto in fin dei
conti
ho riflettuto su quello che è lo spazio
e del perché lo trovo un lavoro così
appassionante e allora ho scavato un po
nella memoria e anche riflettuto sul
presente
lo spazio oggi è assolutamente
fondamentale per moltissime attività
sulla terra e quindi per sostenere la
nostra vita qui la vita sostenibile un
pianeta sostenibile ma è anche
l'immaginifico che ognuno di noi la
voglia disperata di esplorare di
conoscere di più dove siamo
l'evoluzione del nostro sistema solare e
magari perché no cercare di capire il
nostro futuro
e allora ho pensato che forse il taglio
poteva essere diverso
sì magari qualche elemento fattuale da
ingegnere ci poteva essere
ci poteva essere anche un po di visione
un po di emozione ticosa è lo spazio
oggi allora parto da un emozione di
tanti anni fa quella di un'immagine in
bianco e nero che mi rapì la prima
l'impronta dell'uomo sulla luna e mi
impresse una volontà non di voler fare
l'astronauta
ma lo ricordo bene di costruire le
macchine che potevano consentire
all'uomo di andare nello spazio
un secondo momento di grande emozione
anche di ingegneria possono provare
quando da un mondo lontano titano
ricevemmo i primi bit dopo tante ore di
viaggio radio bene aver contribuito a
progettare gli equipaggiamenti che
consentirono quel collegamento radio
abbastanza incredibile un disco volante
che attutito da un paracadute atti tana
trasmette i dati alla sonda madre
cassini
la sonda madre circa 5 tonnellate di
hardware si volta gentilmente verso la
terra di trasmette a terra
bene quando arrivano con i primi big
compresi che anche gli ingegneri infine
conti anno e delle emozioni marte da
sempre fa parte del nostro immaginifico
da sempre ci interroghiamo sulle diverse
forme di vita che possono esserci in
modalità più o meno fantasiose
fantascientifica e non da sempre ma
negli ultimi decenni ci interroghiamo su
che macchine mandare su marte per capire
che tipo di vita c'è stato e se c'è
stato ma marte anche il nostro piano b
per definizione è probabilmente il primo
non voglio dire l'ultimo perché non
voglio limitare la nostra immaginazione
luogo dove poter immaginare un umanità
che colonizza pianeti e allora da sempre
ci procura grande grande fascino e ci
attrae è però marte questo marzia
un'atmosfera debolissima molto tenue una
pressione di meno di un centesimo di
quella terrestre è una temperatura media
di meno 63 gradi quella terrestre in
media è di 14 gradi e quindi posto
un pochino inospitale diciamo anche
protetti da me l'avete spaziali l'uomo
sarebbe colpito da fortissime radiazioni
e allora per poter immaginare in un
futuro magari lontano la possibilità di
abitare su quel pianeta dobbiamo
interrogarci su un processo po complessa
una parola un po difficile
il terraforming la terra formazione
ovvero come poter ricreare
artificialmente su quel pianeta delle
condizioni di atmosfera compatibili con
la fisiologia umana ed è un processo
possibile beh gli scienziati si sono
interrogati su questo e ad esempio
attraverso venti anni di missioni
robotizzate di rover di sonde hanno
fatto un inventario del biossido di
carbonio presente sul pianeta ce n'è
molto allora un'interrogazione è una
domanda è bene ma se riuscissimo a
liberarlo ad esempio dalle calotte o
dalle rocce dove immagazzinato e
riuscissimo ad alzare la temperatura del
pianeta su scala globale
potremmo immaginare che quelle riserve
di ghiaccio sotto la superficie di marte
ha incidentalmente ghiaccio su marte
l'hanno scoperto strumenti molto
sofisticati
beh l'italia ha partecipato e ha
partecipato molto attivamente a quelle
scoperte a quegli strumenti bene se noi
riuscissimo ad alzare la temperatura e
quindi a rendere liquida quell'acqua
potremmo probabilmente far tornare
indietro quel pianeta di qualche
miliardo di anni 3 miliardi 3 miliardi e
mezzo e quindi riportare sul pianeta
una condizione che forse è stata e che
quando andiamo a esplorare quando
andiamo a esplorare i crateri e gli
alvei dei fiumi ci riporta questo
lontano passato
il pianeta è ma c'è un problema il
problema è che anche se dovessimo
liberare tutta l'anidride carbonica
presente in quel pianeta e quindi
generare effetto serra non sarebbe
sufficiente ci porterebbe a triplicare
l'attuale pressione e forse ad aumentare
la temperatura globale del pianeta di 10
o 15 gradi e poi marte non ha un campo
magnetico a dei focolari e magnetici e
senza campo magnetico anche quell
atmosfera più debole che potremmo
riuscire a ricostruire verrebbe spazzata
via dal vento solare come avviene da
miliardi di anni
e allora per non perdere la visione e
l'immaginifico delle colonie su marte
beh forse dobbiamo pensare qualcosa di
diverso e già stiamo pensando qualcosa
di diverso
la stessa comunità scientifica ci dice
che ad esempio se usassimo degli aerei
air di silicio quindi una sorta di di
spuma anche di pochi centimetri bene
quello strato bloccherebbe gran parte
delle radiazioni ultraviolette lasciando
passare la luce e quindi potrebbe
portare a un innalzamento della
temperatura nell'area e anche
potenzialmente a processi di fotosintesi
e quindi se riuscissimo a sciogliere
quell'acqua sotto quell'area quella
grande area potremmo utilizzarla e
potremmo utilizzarla per fare cosa
beh ad esempio ice house case di
ghiaccio case di ghiaccio sì questo è il
primo premio della nasa dato a un team
di ingegneri di architetti che ha
immaginato
la stampa in tre dimensioni prelevando
acqua dal sottosuolo marziano e
costruendo degli ambienti degli ambienti
di ghiaccio e naturalmente per quello
che abbiamo detto una volta costruiti
gli rimarrebbero per la temperatura
esterna del pianeta
e allora potremmo cominciare a
utilizzare quelle tecnologie che già
oggi abbiamo i moduli pressurizzati quei
moduli che fanno vivere i nostri
astronauti attorno alla terra nella
stazione spaziale internazionale e
avvolgerli con queste coperture di
viaggio che al tempo stesso
bloccherebbero gli ultravioletti
ma lascerebbero passare la luce e magari
nell'intercapedine dare delle aree dove
far crescere le piante
anche perché se vogliamo essere coloni
spaziali in un lontano futuro non
possiamo più portare tutto dalla terra e
quindi dovremmo rigenerare dobbiamo
rigenerare sul pianeta quello che ci
serve per poterci lavorare
e allora come un filo rosso come il
pianeta marte che ci collega tra terra e
marte
capiamo perché è importante la luna nei
prossimi anni torniamo sulla luna per
restarci
non per una scampagnata di pochi giorni
torniamo sulla luna per restarci perché
sarà il nostro laboratorio il nostro
laboratorio di operai spaziali lavorare
sul pianeta per capire quello che
possiamo fare è come quando si
costruisce una nuova infrastruttura
beh abbiamo bisogno di una base
logistica quindi ci sarà una stazione in
orbita cise lunare italia ci partecipa
in maniera molto importante alla
costruzione da quella stazione in orbita
ci sono rare
gli astronauti andranno da e per la luna
che opereranno sulla luna e sulla luna
cominceranno a sperimentare la
possibilità di vivere e strutture
pressurizzate e perché no di capire come
proteggersi dalle radiazioni
utilizzando il materiale presente sulla
luna costruendo delle delle strutture
operando con delle macchine che
aiuteranno l'uomo e allora sì un
orizzonte più vicino
possiamo immaginare che la luna sia
laboratorio di vere e proprie colonie e
poi portare quel sogno più lontano
amarth ce la facciamo da soli
probabilmente no analogamente a quanto
viene avviene sulla terra
l'intelligenza artificiale è
un'evoluzione è una rivoluzione che
stiamo vivendo
avremo bisogno e abbiamo bisogno quindi
di macchine che opereranno assieme con
l'uomo che moltiplicheranno le sue
capacità che costruiranno autonomamente
e che magari controllate dall uomo a
terra o sulla stazione spaziale attorno
al pianeta o anche sul pianeta luna e
marte che siano ci aiuteranno a queste
costruzioni e a queste colonie spaziali
e allora torno su quella sensazione
quella visione quell'emozione che lo
spazio ha inevitabilmente in ognuno di
noi e anche in coloro che operano ogni
giorno affinché affinché questo sia
possibile
l'esplorazione planetaria luna marte ed
oltre
è una sfida di tecnologia certamente una
sfida di ingegneria ma anche una sfida
di donne e di uomini che porteranno in
questo viaggio le loro emozioni e quindi
è in fin dei conti la nostra natura
lo spazio e queste tecnologie ci
aiuteranno per sempre
a esplorare da dove siamo venuti e dove
potremmo andare grazie
[Applauso]